alerte à la bergerie nationale à
rambouillet un peu avant les vacances un
voleur a subtilisé un dossier
confidentiel et projette de construire
une ferme usine l'établissement a donc
mis en place une enquête grandeur nature
et demande de l'aide aux visiteurs et
plus particulièrement aux enfants qu'il
fallait résoudre le voleur qui avait
volé les animaux ils la voulaient ou
cheval fait y aller regarder sur voyard
des choses et du coup on a résolu
l'enquète et du coup même si ces
craintes des traces de pieds des indices
ont été disséminés dans plusieurs
bâtiments et dans un labyrinthe végétal
une animation qui permettent également
de découvrir l'environnement et les
pratiques agricoles de la bergerie
nationale le but de faire réfléchir aux
6 ans les enfants sur cette enquête
c'est que voilà l'idée qu'il découvre ce
qui est un peu l'agroécologie en quoi il
ya le bien-être animal sur la bergerie
nationale une enquête à résoudre en
famille afin de récompenser le visiteur
d'avoir mis la main sur le coupable la
bergerie offre une entrée gratuite
très bien très bien très bien ça ça aide
tout le monde aux fins de les enfants
réfléchissent c'est pas très très
compliqué donc c'est assez adaptés pour
tous les âges et c'est pas mal comme la
suite est aussi profond aussi proche
s'il vient et on passe un bon après midi
l'enquète à la ferme a lieu tous les
jours de 14 heures à 16 heures jusqu'au
23 février
une animation complété par l'accès à la
traite des vaches ou encore les soins
aux animaux